Es la primera vez que están en esta
tienda comunitaria Así que la voluntaria
del ejército de salvación Explica las
normas Los visitantes pueden comprar
diversos productos a cambio de una
pequeña contribución económica
estoy entusiasmada voy a hervir la mitad
y a comerme la otra mitad cruda
nala siempre trabajó hasta que dio a luz
a su hijo el crédito universal y las
prestaciones por hijos son sus únicos
ingresos
esto nos ha salvado
solo calentar mi casa anoche porque
estábamos a 4 grados bajo cero me costó
5 libras
Mi hijo tiene tres años y medio Así que
todavía es pequeño cuando hace este frío
compartimos la cama se queda en mi
habitación
antes podía permitirse llevar a su hijo
a un restaurante dos veces al mes ahora
es imposible con la subida de los
precios de la energía
me gastaba 40 o 50 libras cuando hacía
frío 55 quizás quieres saber cuánto pago
ahora 180 libras cómo puede ser que el
gobierno piense que esto es aceptable
para las personas es repugnante
en esta zona de clase trabajadora del
este de Londres el ejército de salvación
también ofrece asesoramiento profesional
y ayuda con la solicitudes en línea
depende de los voluntarios y a menudo de
los supermercados para llenar las
estanterías de su tienda ahora nuevas
caras llegan hasta aquí por comida
tenemos un equilibrio de personas hay
gente que tiene acceso a fondos gente
que recibe prestaciones pero también
bastantes personas que trabajan la
mayoría a tiempo parcial lo que he visto
en el último año no se parece a nada que
haya visto antes las historias que estoy
escuchando la crisis de la vivienda la
crisis del coste de la vida es
simplemente fuera de escalar
tiene la segunda tasa más alta de
pobreza infantil en el país y muchas
familias dependen de las organizaciones
de Caridad como ejércitos de salvación
para sobrevivir los voluntarios son
esenciales ya sea dando comida dinero o
ropa pero las organizaciones de Caridad
más pequeñas y poco conocidas tienen
problemas en medio de esta crisis
económica